Kentucky is Tom hey Tom how are you
alright Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I recently came in some
money and I paid off my credit card and
I have enough left to pay off my car but
I will only have like a thousand dollars
left to put in my savings I was just
wondering what your thought was okay
well we teach a process for becoming
wealthy called the baby steps and the
first premise of that is that your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and so we teach people and it has
been very successful doing this to get
out of debt and without any debt
payments they have the money then to
start investing and being generous and
those are the things that cause people
to become wealthy so what do you make a
year me and my wife make about a hundred
and ten hundred and twenty somewhere in
that neighborhood all right and so until
you came into this money you were
basically broke making a hundred grand
huh pretty much yeah so it's time to
change some habits would you agree yeah
okay so if you're going to do all of
that then I can show you the whole
process and you can do this simply doing
part of what I teach could leave you
vulnerable and I don't want you to do
that in other words yes I would take the
money and pay off the car and have a
thousand dollars left because our baby
step one is pay off all debt except your
home that's maybe step two and use any
money that you have above a thousand
dollars to do that so baby step ones a
thousand dollars saved baby step two has
become debt free but your home would
that leave you 100 percent debt free
except your home if you did that if you
paid off the car yes okay and then what
we would have you do is be on a written
detailed budget you and your spouse and
agreement of exactly where this hundred
and something thousand dollars a year is
gonna go on paper on purpose before the
month begins every month as if I hired
you to manage this company and your job
was to make this money behaving you'd
have to report on how it went
and then it go to what you said it was
going to go to for the good of you right
and so you know you know you you then
would build up an emergency fund out of
that budget of three to six months of
expenses and then we would start
investing for retirement and you'd have
the money to do so with no payments but
a house payment and be living on a plan
making a hundred grand and so that's the
whole process of what we would teach you
if you simply pay off the car and have a
thousand dollars you're right back where
you were before you got the money except
you don't have a car payment and if you
keep not handling money well and making
a hundred thousand dollars and having
nothing you're going to end up back in
debt again agreed right and so what we
have to do is change the process that
got you to where you are and we'll use
this extra round money as some rocket
fuel to get you off the ground in the
new direction and so hold on I'll send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover it will show you exactly how to
do all of this in detail and it goes
through the seven baby steps and I'll
give it to you as a Christmas present
and this will help you get moving
and you call me back if you get any more
questions as you go along I'm here to
help